-That's right, earlier this
morning, President Trump tweeted
about Congress' ongoing
impeachment inquiry.
He wrote, "All Republicans
must remember
what they are witnessing here -
a lynching."
Now, the complex issues
surrounding a white person
using the term lynching
is not something I'm
comfortable talking about.
-But I am!
[ Laughter
and applause ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, Donald Trump,
you raggedy bastard!
-[Chuckle]
-You're not being lynched!
You know how I know?
Because people
who are being lynched
don't sit in a mansion,
tweeting about bull[bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Look, the reason
you're comfortable comparing
your situation to a lynching
is because you value
Black people so little
that, in your mind,
a Black person dying
is equal to your
slight discomfort.
Well, you know what causes
my slight discomfort?
Listening to you breathe.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Huffing, puffing ]
It's like you're breathing
through a hole
humans don't have.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I keep hearing people say,
"This is a distraction."
The president saying racist
things isn't a distraction.
It's a real thing that makes
real Americans feel unsafe.
This is a distraction.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Jenny.
-You're welcome!
-Now, it's no surprise
Trump is a racist
because his dad was a racist.
His dad was arrested, in 1927,
near a Klan rally.
Now, that doesn't prove
that he was in the Klan,
but, if you see me
near a Cinnabon,
it's not 'cause I love
waitin' in line.
[ Laughter, cheer ]
And you will see me
at a Cinnabon.
[ Laughter ]
The impeachment inquiry
is not a lynching.
Don't believe me?
Ask your Klan-ass dad.
[ Laughter ]
You think the impeachment
inquiry is an injustice.
It's not!
It's the direct consequence
of your actions!
Injustice was what the Lord did
to your face and body.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Bye-ye-ye-ye-ye-ye-ye!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]